dude hey if you were a mock turtleneck
after Steve Jobs era watch dude dude
it's like having the Hitler mustache
straight up Charlie Chaplin had it okay
then Hitler was like this is how I'm
wrong to me and then you can't have it
after that Michael Jordan tried about
[ __ ] 12 years earlier when he was on
a Hanes commercial dude that was the
most ballin ass [ __ ] I've ever seen when
Michael Jordan was on the Haynes
commercial in the airplane and he was
like sure I'll do it and he showed up in
a Hitler mustache dude that is the most
ballin ass [ __ ] cuz you know Hanes when
they ship when he showed up on the
[ __ ] day of shooting Haynes was just
like oh like they were literally like
look up the scene in Big Lebowski where
Philip Seymour Hoffman when when what's
the girl's name
Todd Tara Reid is like I'll suck your
dick for $300 and he's just like and
then and then Philip Seymour Hoffman
goes oh oh that was what Hanes was like
that was what Hanes was like when
Michael Jordan showed up in his [ __ ]
Hitler mustache to hawk underwear they
all went oh what Philip Seymour Hoffman
does right there right there
seven seconds into the clip uh-huh
that's what the Haines people did I'll
suck your dick for $100 oh she jokes a
lot that was the face Haines made dude
Michael Jordan hey dude I'm sorry but
when Michael Jordan even know how to say
this but when I it like in 2008 or 9
when I found out
there was an actor named Michael B
Jordan I was like that's that
[ __ ] dude that that guy is the
[ __ ] you know what dude it would have
been only the more of the [ __ ] is if he
dropped the B and was like I'm gonna be
an actor named Michael Jordan [ __ ] the
best basketball player in the world like
but and then I tweeted at one side that
guy's name is Michael Jordan I think
somebody tweeted back the B is for
basketball which is hilarious but that
would be like like if I had was an actor
and my name was Steve Q jobs Chanel